what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar and today we are going to be
talking about arguably the coolest clan
in naruto
the uchihas i made this video because
you guys really liked the all seven
hokage and their powers explained video
and suggested this topic in the comments
of that one
so same thing here if you want to keep
seeing naruto videos on the channel
make sure to turn that like button blue
and share this video with your naruto
friends
as soon as the video hits 4 000 likes
i'll get started on the next one asap
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell or you will miss future naruto
videos on the channel
like last time leave suggestions for
videos about different clans or
characters you want to see in the
comments
and it may just be the next naruto video
you see keep in mind all spoilers are
fair game you've been warned now without
further ado
let's jump into it though jihad clan was
called by kakashi the most elite family
in the hidden leaf village
though chiha were a rival clan to the
senju clan
until they decided to come together and
form the hidden leaf village
because of the uchiha incident where
hitachi and toby took out almost the
entire clan
there are few uchiha left i'm not gonna
get into too much detail here but
hitachi
chiha did it a because do chiha were
planning a coup
and b to save the life of his little
brother sasuke hitachi then took on the
role of villain in the public's eye
even though he was secretly the hero of
the hidden leaf village
and the savior of his little brother
sasuke though chihaclan are descendants
of indra otsutsuki
the older son of hagoromo otsutsuki aka
the sage of six paths like indra though
chiha tend to be associated with
powerful emotions
a so-called curse of hatred the idea of
peace through
power rather than peace through love and
the now famous shotgun their shot and
guns let them see chakra use genjutsu
copy the techniques of their opponents
and more the shotting gun can evolve
into the more powerful mangekyo shot and
gun
and even into a renagon but we'll get
more into those details later
notably though chiha are also known for
flexing on their opponents with their
legendary fire release techniques
but back to indra the ancestor of do
chihaz for a second
indro's younger brother asura was chosen
to succeed his father and the senju clan
came from him
obviously indra was not happy with his
father's decision
and the clash between the two brothers
with their different powers and
ideologies continued even after their
deaths through their descendants
now let's get into some specific uchihas
and their unique powers
keep in mind i won't mention every
uchiha ever to appear in a manga panel
but rather i'll be focusing on every
notable jihad whose power has been
revealed
first off let's look at itachiochiha fan
favorite and definitely a contender for
the best big bro
in all of anime i'll be paying special
attention to mangekyo shot and guns in
this video
since each one has a unique interesting
power and itachi had awakened it the
mangekyo shotangan is an advanced form
or evolved form of the shotgun the
mangekyo shot and gun pattern looks
different depending on the person it is
activated when a user witnesses the
death of someone close to them
and for hitachi that was the death of
his best friend shisuyuchiha
though chihas have mistakenly believed
that you have to actually
kill the person closest to you in order
to activate it but that's not actually
the case
the activation might not happen right
after the trauma
but even weeks later the mangekyo
shoting gun is a huge strain on the user
and will eventually lead to blindness
this blindness can be avoided if the
user obtains the eternal mangekyo
shotgun by
transplanting the eyes of another closeu
chiha preferably that of a sibling
in itachi's case his left eye can use
tsukuyomi
which has been referred to as the most
powerful genjutsu it allows hitachi to
alter his victims perception of
time by doing so he can subject people
to days of torture
in just a few seconds hitachi uses
tsukuyomi
on kakashi so kakashi experiences 72
hours
of continually being stabbed however
tokyomi doesn't have to be used for just
torture
in one of the most romantic moments ever
hitachi used it on izumi uchiha a girl
who loved him before she died
so that she'd experience a long happy
life she died in a moment
but she experienced marrying hitachi
having kids and growing old when she
finally died in the illusion she died in
the real world too
where only a second had passed that's
some deep stuff
hitachi's right eye can use amaterasu
which creates
inextinguishable black flames amaterasu
is considered to be the highest level of
fire release
it's opaf until it stops working on
villains like the otsutsuki's
originally we were told that the black
flames never go
out until they have burned their target
to ash however the user can put out the
flames
if he so chooses when one awakens both
their mangekyo
eyes like hitachi they can use susano
susano is called by sasuke an absolute
defense
that is even greater than gara's famous
absolute defense
sort of like naruto in the nine-tailed
fox users of the susano can be suspended
in it
as they control the giant chakra avatar
kind of like a mecca
itachi susano possesses the sword of
totsuka which is capable of sealing the
enemy it pierces
it comes out of a jar and those it
pierces will be drawn into the jar and
trapped in a genjutsu
of drunken dreams forever the sword can
also be used as a regular sword so it
has versatility in that regard hitachi
susano also has the yata mirror a shield
that is said to deflect all things with
this combination black zatsu says that
hitachi was invincible even with
hitachi's terminal illness
he could have still beat sasuke in their
fight if he actually wanted to
eventually sasuke takes hitachi's eyes
in order to attain the eternal mangekyo
shotting god itachi was also very fast
and skilled in taijutsu
he would summon crows and even use them
to create clones of himself he was
skilled with a sword kunai and he
notably mastered
chiha clan's great fireball technique at
a very young age
and as we know he was always regarded as
a genius and one of the best users of
genjutsu
there are obviously even more details
that one can mention about hitachi but
because of the nature of this video
which is about highlighting a number of
people
i'm going to move on if you guys want to
see a video entirely devoted to hitachi
let me know in the comments below next
let's look at the god of shinobi's
greatest rival madarao chiha
the meteoric legend himself imagine the
pinnacle of the uchiha clan with some
hashirama cells and truth-seeking orbs
thrown in
and you get a very op villain yes our
main character surpassed him eventually
but it's a shonen so you can't really
hold that against him mandara was
actually the first uchiha to awaken the
mangekyo sharingan although some believe
that madara took his brother izuna's
eyes by force
he actually got the eternal mangekyo
shotgun when his dying brother willingly
offered him his eyes so that he could
use them to help protect the uchihas
madala's perfect susanoo is huge and
with its katana-like blades it can
easily cut through mountains
madara boasts that a single stroke of
his susano's blade
contains enough power to smash all
things in the universe
his susanoo practically had the five
kage shaking in their boots
unfortunately we don't know what his
unique mangekyo powers
are but we do know that his mangekyo
shotting guns evolved into renagons
which are called by jiraiya the most
noble of the three great ocular jutsu
which also include the shoting god and
the byakugan
the sage of six paths the father of
al-shinobi was the first to obtain the
renagon and its power
is legendary those who have it are
either expected to calm the world
or reduce it to nothingness the renegade
allows one to use the six paths
technique
through which they can attract things
repel things mechanically enhance their
bodies read people's minds and yank out
their souls
summon multiple creatures absorb chakra
summon the king of hell
revive the dead and even more with his
renagon madara could create
shadows of himself in a limbo world that
coexists with the physical world with
two
renagons he can create up to four
shadows they have his powers and they
are invisible in the real world but they
can actually attack opponents or defend
against their attacks
so to outsiders it just looks like
they're getting beaten up by nobody
or like madara has an invisible barrier
around him
unfortunately for madara sasuke's
renagon can see the shadows and
six-path sage mode naruto can sense them
in the past
madara transplanted his renagon eyes
into a child nagato but eventually got
them back
as the tenth tales jinchuriki with two
renagon eyes
madra was able to awaken the renee
shotting on on his forehead
which lets one use the moon to cast
infinite tsukuyomi
on the people of the world plus he could
use the roots of the god tree to ensnare
his genjutsu victims
and siphon chakra off of them not to
mention madra also had truth seeking
orbs at one point which can nullify
ninjutsu
or can just be used to defend and attack
with style
there's so much more that can be
explored about this hashirama cell
having meteor dropping
all nature transformations using ten
tails and renagon possessing mad lad but
that's
so long video and once again if you want
a dedicated video about any of these
guys
let me know in the comments below next
let's look at obito chiha the childhood
friend
and rival of kakashi turned madara
impersonator he awakened his mangekyo
sharingan
nohara the girl he loved died obito just
had one of his eyes at the time while
kakashi had the other both eyes awakened
at the same time
both eyes can use kamui a space-time
ninjutsu
that lets the user transfer objects to
and from another dimension
obito's right eye is able to transfer
parts of the user's body or their entire
body
to the other dimension so that attacks
appear to simply pass through the user's
body
in this way obito's body can be
completely intangible
and as a result he can pass through
walls or even the ground
he can only keep his body completely
intangible for around
five minutes and he cannot teleport in
this state thus when he solidifies in
preparation for teleportation
he is vulnerable he can transfer himself
or others to the kamui dimension by
sucking them into his eye but it appears
like they have
to be close to him he can also enter the
kamui dimension and return to any
location he pleases
so in a way it's like an improved flying
thunder god technique
where you don't have to use pre-existing
marks the kamui dimension can store
weapons that obito could launch at
opponents or he could use the dimension
as a safe place to retreat to
since the only way to get there is by
using obito's eyes
people he transfers to that dimension
have no way out
unless they have access to one of his
eyes in contrast
the left eye has more of a long-range
focus
it can create a barrier space around an
object in the distance and teleport it
to the kamui dimension the object is
sucked into the barrier space
rather than into the eye when kakashi
first starts using it he tends to have
trouble with accuracy and often misses
his target he also has trouble creating
a big enough barrier space
however eventually he becomes skilled
enough to warp flying weapons and to
create large barriers
kakashi even figures out how to create
the barrier around himself
in doing so he can transport himself
into the kamui dimension
and thus also make use of teleportation
the more chakra you have
the better you can make use of these
powers when kakashi received some nine
tails chakra
he said that kamui was three times more
powerful and he could even transport
eight tails
in and out of the kamui dimension so
yeah obito's kamui is potentially very
strong
especially in the hands of an ochiha who
wouldn't drain chakra using it as fast
as kakashi
when both eyes use kamui at the same
time kamui will be performed at double
the speed
and with both of obito's eyes the user
can use susano when kakashi uses the
full body susano he is able to launch
giant kamui shuriken which will teleport
targets to the kamui dimension on
contact
because obito's body contained white
zetsu matter and white zetsu mater was
partially derived from hashirama's dna
obito could perform would release the
first hokage's opie nature
transformation kekagenkai that combined
earth and water
he also got to use madras rinagon for a
time and he got to flex on people
as the ten tales jinchuriki with his own
truth seeking orbs
at the height of obito's power even the
first hokage the so-called god of
shinobi
was like yup that dude is stronger than
me so props to obito
started out as a sort of screw-up
compared to the more naturally talented
kakashi for now let's move on to sasuke
uchiha
our protagonist's main friend and rival
throughout the series he awakened his
mangekyo shoting gun after his brother
died with his left eye he can use a
matarasu and with his right eye he can
manipulate the black flames or put them
out
as mentioned he took his brother's eyes
and awakened the eternal mangekyo
shotting god so he doesn't have to worry
about vision loss anymore
eventually he gained half of the sage of
six paths chakra
and as a result his left eye evolved
into rinnegan sasuke's rinagon lets him
shift himself between spaces aka
teleport to a nearby place
if he chooses a space being occupied he
swaps places with that person or thing
he can also create portals into
different dimensions
obviously with two mangekyo shotting on
eyes sasuke can use susano
with his rinigon he can use the wings of
his susano
to block out the infinite tsukuyomi
sasuke can also use his signature move
chidori through his susano the giant
chidori could match the power of a biju
ball from naruto's nine tails
sasuke susano also possesses a bow and
he can strengthen the projectiles by
mixing in black flames or lightning
just like madara has wrapped his susano
around the nine tails in the past
sasuke has similarly wrapped his susano
around naruto's nine tails which is one
of my favorite combos in the series
along with naruto sasuke is considered
to be the strongest shinobi naruto and
sasuke's combined power is considered to
be able to destroy the world which may
not be a big deal in dragon ball
but it sure is a naruto sasuke lost an
arm like naruto in the series but that
hasn't slowed him down or made him
weaker in boruto
he could potentially use an artificial
arm like naruto but it seems like he
doesn't even want to bother with that at
this point
next let's look at shisuyuchiha itachi's
homeboy
shisui awakened his mangekyo shotgun
after his own friend and teammate died
on a dangerous mission with each of his
eyes
shisui could use koto amatsukami a
subtle mind control genjutsu it is such
a top tier genjutsu that the victim
never even catches on to being
manipulated the target believes that
they are
choosing to act in accordance with their
own free will for these reasons
it's been called the ultimate genjutsu a
biakugan can
catch the genjutsu being used though
perhaps because it's so powerful this
genjutsu can usually only be used once
every 10 or more years however there is
a loophole
if you have hashirama chakra you can use
the genjutsu more often
even with his hashirama cells donzo says
that it's not a genjutsu he can use many
times a day but he can clearly use it
way more frequently than once a decade
at one point shisui wanted to use this
kenjutsu to avoid the uchiha clan
downfall
but his right eye was stolen by danzo
who definitely wasn't a fan of that plan
donzo used it over the years to do shady
danzo things
while the other eye was given to hitachi
hitachi put in a crow and then put the
crow in naruto weird i know
when naruto saw sasuke with his
transplanted itachi eyes the crow would
have convinced sasuke to save konoha
rather than to attack it however due to
the edo tensei
it ended up being used on hitachi
himself both donzo and itachi destroyed
the eyes so nobody else could use them
that's how dangerous even these
experienced and skilled fighters
consider them to be
we don't see shisui susano in action in
any canon materials but in the naruto
games he has a green version that has a
drill like lance
and it can also shoot chakra needles at
opponents lastly i'll point out that
shisui had much more going for him than
just his mind control
in the manga shisui was said to be one
of the most talented uchiha
and the best ever at teleportation
however shisui used insane speed to
seemingly teleport notably his body
flicker or teleportation technique
is not actually a space-time ninjutsu
like sasuke's space shifting ability
next let's look at sara daochiha the
daughter of our boy sasuke and one of
the main characters of the boruto series
like naruto did she wants to become
hokage and boruto wants to become a
great shinobi so he can support her
sarada has yet to awaken her mangekyo
shot and gone so we don't know what her
unique mangekyo powers will be
but she is skilled with her shotgun she
can use her eyes to do regular shot and
gone things like cask and jutsu
the spell genjutsu sea chakra and copy
techniques she's also been able to use
her shot and gun like a microscope in
order to clearly see something as small
as viruses
she has sakura's devastatingly powerful
punches having learned how to focus
chakra into her fists
sarada is known as being the best among
her peers at throwing kunai
notably she can already use though
chiha's great fireball technique
and the chidori and i'm not gonna lie
when i saw her use the chili for the
first
time that was a very hyped moment for me
with sadhara she clearly has a lot of
room to grow especially if she's going
to become hokage so i expect to see way
more impressive things from her
as the borto series progresses those are
all the big uchihas that we actually
have a significant amount of info about
beyond these there are some others that
haven't been highlighted as much
and haven't played as big of a role in
the series there's fugaku
chiha the father of hitachi and sasuke
who was the head of the jihad clan
and the leader of the konoha military
police force
in the novels fugaku was said to be a
rare genius he was so talented that
people compared him to minato namikaze
and the legendary 3 which adds another
parallel between sasuke and naruto since
their fathers were comparable just as
they were
in fact some uchihas felt like fugaku
should have become the fourth hokage
instead of minato
fugaku could notably produce an
especially massive great fireball and he
had obviously awakened the shotgun
in the anime he awakened the mangekyo
shotgun and he believed that he was
strong enough to control the ninetails
it's also worth mentioning that mikoto
chiha sasuke's mom was a droning
then there's hitachi's almost girlfriend
izumi who awakened her shotting gun even
before hitachi
she was especially good at taijutsu and
she graduated a year earlier than others
but she did have trouble with chakra
levels using her shotting gun would
cause her to faint
rather quickly keep in mind izumi was
featured in the novels and in the anime
and the two sources differ in their
details
i definitely recommend the novels if you
want to learn more about her izunau
chiha was the tobi rama of dochiha clan
he was madada's brother and together
they were considered to be the two
strongest of chihas of their time
he did awaken the mangekyo shotting gun
although we don't know what its unique
powers were he then gave his eyes to
madara
so that madara could gain the eternal
mangekyo shotting god eyes and used them
to protect do chihas
in the anime we also learned an
interesting amount about kagami uchiha
contemporary of the third hokage and
danzo
he saved danzo multiple times and shisui
said that he was
inferior to kagami shisui was actually
kagami's descendant
again we should take all these details
with a grain of salt because they're not
in the original manga
but i thought they were interesting
enough to add here and that's pretty
much it for the
chihas that we know enough about for me
to talk about in this video thank you
for watching and sticking through to the
end it's much appreciated especially
since this probably will turn out to be
a long video
if you did enjoy it and want to see more
like it for other clans then use the
body flicker technique to turn that like
button blue
and share this video with your naruto
loving friends as soon as we hit
4 000 likes that's right 4 000 on this
one i'll get started on the next naruto
video asap
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell or you will miss future naruto
videos
as always leave video suggestions for
clans and or specific characters you'd
like to see me cover next
in the comments and who knows i may get
to all of your glorious ideas eventually
lastly the youtube ad rates have
significantly dropped recently
so the help and support we're getting
from our anime opera patrons is now more
important than ever
a very special thank you goes out to our
patrons over on patreon who help us
survive these youtube issues and who
help make videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
legend acknowledged by lord tuigo
himself
efrenay and the one-tier patrons the
ones who stand atop
all clans stephen and grotta alolan
attemp the world steelers acquire
respect but they have a jonathan king
desi d brandon of isles papa smurf the
school bus
king riser emperor otaku richie martinez
and thomas jones
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh nothing but a fan
jason wilson kings out just anatoly
kazatsky angel cruz qriket xp
joe stanton very gucci alicia actor
jessica kayla fond hinokami and water
bonnie park zodiar12 rathuen de ora tien
huang
cynical kraken fulgus77 and deadly saint
thank you all so much if you enjoy our
work you can support more of it by going
over to patreon.com
anime pro and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get a name featured
in future videos alongside these amazing
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life
and of course dank memes so check out
patreon.com anime outpour link in the
description if you're interested you can
also now join the youtube channel and
support more content that way if you
prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see you
space cowboys
[Music]
you